so there's no a better timing to talk
about batteries compared to now so when
I was in white I was thinking you know
what do what do I want to share with you
when I was hired 14 years ago coming to
the faculty and that wall was really the
starting time I learned myself and
learned for my students we taught each
other all the way for 13 years until
nowadays these 13 years you have seen
many great things happen our form
integration is better and better we see
the drawing is coming up even my two
boys have a you know DJ I to play with
we see tasks like Heights
everywhere in Palo Alto and our parking
lot and stand for right here you can see
a big number right now this is getting
more and more California has the
requirement we have the Renewable of 50%
just in another several years less than
ten years it's about seven years from
now so this all call for what's the idea
for energy storage the table is for
portable the bottom row is stationary
they have beef in requirement but they
share is that this common parameters
right there these are the parameters we
are looking for how much energy you stop
per unit weight or volume for your phone
is this wild per liter that's more
important for your car while per kilo is
more important one is by wall and the
other is by weight the cost when I
started and 2000 to 2005 the benefit
cost was of $400 per kilowatt hour and
the sale level and is going down so fast
I'm going to show you next
my lifetime how many cycles you can go
through and in calendar life if you
don't use it just let it sit right there
can you let it sit for 10 years or 20
years you can still use it this is
important particularly for the car and
for the grease scale how fast can you
charge it whether you can make it safe
or not this continued to be the
questions you never stop asking until
nowadays well if you look at how the
batteries work well let's come to the
battery 101 you take a cylinder cell
that's in the tesla car and you cut it
open it has this jerry roll if you zoom
in and look at this you have copper foil
aluminum foil
now people try to push the limit in a
couple of oil 5 micron 7 micron aluminum
foil less than 10 micron and this is the
battery separator right a separating and
no and cathode and mill consists of
these particles as well as cathode they
can stow leave them in there in their
crystal structure once you charge your
battery leave them go to a no electrons
also come to a no they meet in the end
no that's in charge of state and in the
discharges state they go back to cathode
back and forth whether about is can work
or not you need to deal with these
issues these determines a lot about how
the bear is work whether it's safe how
long can you use it for and you need to
move the electrons if you want to charge
your battery fast you better move your
electrons fast ions diffusion these also
a woven no iron squeezed into the
crystal structure any now they will be
strain associate these the crystal
structure because it will be one of
expansion taking place and at the end
interface each of its particles sitting
into a organic electrolyte they need to
be stable and the analyst I particularly
decomposed organic electrolyte and
generate this cell passivation layer so
called a CI this needs to be stay stable
that allow Liam's to come in and go out
but no electrons eventually stop the
psychical reaction so with this basic
structure let's look at where we are
right now this is the existing lithium
ion batteries and where we want to be in
the future and when I started I told you
the cost was about $400 per kilowatt
hour now it's a hundred thirty in the
cell level it's quite significant
reduction of the cost energy density now
roughly about 220 if you use cylinder
size actually 250 when I started was
only a hundred fifty this quite a bit of
improvement right there but we wanted to
go up to five hundred if you have five
hundred water per kilogram mobile
batteries basically a car you drive will
go 400 miles that's roughly the
correlation so that's it for the
kilowatt is 500 water per kilo you get
500 Meyers you actually don't need more
cycle life now we are sitting at about a
thousand cycles after that you have
eighty percent capacity and the calendar
live about seven years we could use more
we would like to go to 10,000 we'd like
to go to twenty five years so after you
finish you're using your car and ten to
twelve years you still have that bear is
still working should be to you like to
agree and use it for the grid this has a
significant impact on the course
charging away one or two hours can you
get them to 10 minutes you have heard a
lot of noise in the literature saying
you can do fast for fast charging so
probably a ninety-five percent or more
of the work is not believable yet
because when they do fast charging they
put in tiny amount of materials on there
and doing a tiny seer they say they can
do a less than 10 minutes or even five
minutes but that's not trustable I'm
talking about here is the real usable
sir can you do less than ten minutes
that's the very
significant challenge right there and
then you need you need to be safe we
don't know how to solve the safety
problem yet we still use organic
electrolyte it can still be burned so we
know you made a lot of progress compared
to 13 years ago but we still have for a
lot of loom to go the outline of the
talk today I want to answer some of the
questions and also allow you to see the
opportunity right there first one is how
far the energy density can go how much
more energy can be packed in a given
size of the batteries the second one is
what in order to make a can we make
immortal batteries does never die then
you need to understand the fundamental
process inside the batteries I want to
highlight a new tool allow us to see
particularly the interface over
batteries I want to come to the battery
safety issue whether it's a hopeless as
long as you use organic for life
you barely won't be safe anymore whether
whether we have solution to solve that
problem and I also like to talk about
grayscale energy storage at the end the
number Five's very important well given
the resources we have all these are the
availability of different element
lithium cobalt and do we have concern
and if you want to be boil at your car
go to a you know a larger scale energy
storage do we have enough resources to
do so let's look at the first one how
how hide energy we can go so that you
come back to the very simple equation to
look for a new chemistry is the energy
equals to wattage multiplied by charge
you need to eat you either need to
increase the wattage or increase the
amount of charge your store and the the
voltage has a limit you see the color
lithium and barely allow you to see
there about forward you know 4.1 4.2 4.3
once we hit to 4.5 you'll actualize
really not that stable no mention of I
won't write the voltage is too high
decompose your electrolyte so there's a
limit right there and the amount of
charge you can stall you have a lot of
room to play with
so eventually want to stall this charge
with the wattage holding right there
using lightweight and small wallet in
the past 27 years graphite has been used
as your negative electrode that's n no
and it has this layer structure lithium
intercalated into the graphite structure
this is the theoretical limit you can
reach we are about that limit right now
this very little very very little um you
can play with but if you use new
material such as silicon or metallic
lithium to store Liam iron your capacity
is 10 times more it's 10 times more so
we have for chemistry right there for
you to have a lot of room to grow for
the cattle side lithium cobalt oxide use
in your cell phone lithium manganese
oxide lithium iron phosphate this has a
two dimensional three dimensional one
dimensional crystal structure channel
for you to store lithium that capacity
also has a limit they are not that high
new material such as sulfur become
lithium sulfur allow you to store also
10x so these chemistry's is really
exciting after about 10 years of
research and it's more broadly what I
will chemistry they are attractive for
the transportation for the grayscale if
you're looking for the chemistry that I
can have practical and mentioning
practical not theoretical high energy
this might be the pathway we have to
follow and now they still graphite
combined with a nickel manganese cobalt
oxide as here X Y Z different ratio and
the maximum you possibly can which is
about 250 watt per kilo
and with silicon replaced Wi-Fi coming
in you get to four hundred and mitel
elysium coming in to replace silicon you
might get to 500 and then software
coming every place MMC combined with
lithium metal you can reach potentially
600 to 800 watt per kilo we have
chemistry allow you to have a runway of
of 3x in a practical sense but this
could take 10-15 years and a practical
sell value see this technology coming
out so the reason is the following this
is a slide I asked my students even to
me this is the reality volume change I
brought it in a way is a lithium versus
the host atom house lethal you notice
that the materials using current
technology is valium six carbon so lead
him to carbon ratio is one to six
lithium cobalt and roughly use half of
the lithium the ratio is one to six
lithium ion phosphate is also about one
to six the volume change right here is
about ten percent or less very small as
soon as you saw a lot of little men to
house these different materials really
start to show up however the amount of
volume expansion you have increased
tremendously
this is the one of the fundamental
reasons to use the high capacity
material is so difficult because the
following problem past 27 years we have
stable host-to-host this rhythm new
materials can store a lot more lithium
has the problem of chemical bond
breaking so many leave them in some way
many electrons coming in store in the
structure you have the bond breaking
atoms are moving all the time for these
house materials very large volume
extraction change big volume expansion
so you need completely new completely
new ideas how do you handle the
materials issue in order to make these
materials workable inside your form
inside your car
so my group started to work on this to
tackle silicon problems silicon has 11x
of the capacity of graphite volume
expansion is four times because breaking
because expand too much and also the
interface on each of the particle
surface is not stable how do you adjust
that problem it wasn't known so let me
show you this video it's quite dramatic
this is the one a silicon gamma
particles inside here we are doing in
situ measurement charge up his particle
with lithium it's 800 nanometers in
diameter to start with and you see
silicon volume expansion and after a
while you know this particle eats her
too much lithium and it's going to get
broken and this breaking and caused the
failure of the battery materials the
first time you charge on your battery is
already dead so that's the challenging
we are facing
so using attending like this we could
identify what's the critical breaking
size after you have the particle small
and then that those sides they won't be
broken any more 150 nanometer is about a
size and these this understanding my
group has been through 11th generation
of design and this was the first
generation we start from silicon
nanowires they have small diameters
volume expansion can happen but they
don't play anymore we solve the breaking
problem this indeed is paper started the
whole research field of what you using
nanotechnology for energy storage
starting from this paper we go to the
course your design and using a stable
core to stabilize the whole structure is
getting better hollow structure design
so you can have interior hollow space
and have more volume to a relaxed
restrain and and and we have been
through now 11 generation each
generation we try to solve our problem
and you can see at this all stacking up
learning now start to build up the
maturities I'm principle for industry to
use and eventually to solve the problem
of volume expansion breaking and
instability of a solid actually
interface so this has a resulting in
companies that start up funded about ten
years ago now having the real batteries
in the market using the phone in the
dome assume we're going to the electric
car and the energy density so we have
the whopper kilo the generation of the
manufacturing line one design in our
China our plant and the line to reach
about 400 watt hour per kilo this is a
lot more than what you know guava NL can
offer so this is a manufacturing plant
and we see city in China 2016 we have
the the whole Board of Directors
visiting the the plan having a
celebration so this is going with a high
promise these could go into the
electoral car in a big way so what's
next after that I'll show you the
roadmap eventually we want to mainly
tomato to work in 2016 the White House
announced the battery 500 consortium the
ECC's this is a consortium and the
Department of Energy providing a 15
million dollars for five years let's try
to generate 500 watt per kilo where more
batteries the PNNL National Lab together
visa Stanford's lacked other co-lead of
this consortium we have a very strong
team of people from a multiple
institution try to adjust this challenge
now we need to come to lithium metal
metallic lithium I show you my talent
lithium can potentially offer as an endo
combine visa nickel manganese cobalt
oxide and we solver with a 500 watt per
kilogram or higher energy density
and you look at half a century ago and
before I was even born and leave him a
bath it really started for me tomato and
now however it was too challenging
people didn't know how to solve the
problem that's because if you start
formally tomato and know it's so
reactive is organic electrolyte if form
an interfacial conquer SGI right away
and then you once you charge your
battery you need to play lithium on to
this lithium foil there's no guarantee
these interface will be flat during
plating you're going to change the
surface topology these will stretch your
sei layer will make a crag or multiple
cracks on the surface this nuclear hot
spot you will grow this filament out of
this hot spot this filament grow longer
and longer can made a bare-faced shortly
happening punches through the separator
and made a better catching fire and
explosion that was indeed a major
challenge you have seen past 10 years
multiple bear for instance many of them
are related to this lithium metallic
lithium dendrite growth cost the battery
catching fire and then when you played a
strip the lithium during discharge
there's no guarantee you will come from
the tip it might go to the bottom then
you are going to cost this filament of
metallic lithium detached from the under
knees Liam Foyle you use lithium metal
very fast the cycling efficiency is very
low you build up this so-called dead
lithium the bear will also die very fast
so for the realistic bear fee for unit
area per centimeter square you need at
least 3 million hour of capacity that
translate to 50 micron thick lithium
metal so every time you play a little
matter you play 60 15 micron thick you
strip away you go back to zero then it
is 15 micron thick and each layer is
just too large for bear is there to
handle we have summarized all this
learning
and these are perspective paper in
nature nanotechnology we combine what
people learn in the past 50 years and
what we learn in our group and we
pointed to the community we said the
lucasz of the problem is actually in the
center outside is the surrounding
phenomena the central problem is high
chemical reactivity of lithium couple
together with relative impending volume
change during a plating and stripping up
and down this process make it very hard
to handle
so these cause all this problem outside
about five years ago Steve come back to
Stanford he and I have a meeting
we brainstorming a lot of ideas how do
we solve this problem so we come up
strategy how do we stabilize the
interface to overcome the high chemical
reactivity problem at the interface we
also point to the community and say no
it chemically need to be stable at the
same time
mechanically needs to be stable
otherwise it's plating and stripping
keep changing your interface putting a
lot of stress on to your interface you
better find an interface that's
chemically and mechanically stable and
how could I we see it we saw it's not
enough because of this 15 micron lithium
plating in and now it's just too
dramatic we need to build a stable host
hosting metallic lithium enzyme and
together with a few other strategies let
me highlight this whole idea what's the
house idea this was done by a graduate
student think-tank was sitting right
there we want to build a house hiding
this metallic lithium in two domain
inside this red collar house if you
strip lead them away this whole
structure remain stable and holding the
whole wall and right there and make it
possible to have an interface you can
build and then when you play lithium it
played into this host
so the attempted develop a very clever
concept so we wanted to use metallic
lithium in the molten State mailed
Elysium embedded into a house we
searched carbon nanotube film as the
house you see this modern lithium they
form jolly they don't wet and which old
have a substrate until we try to reduce
graphene oxide now you see the lithium
melt and wet and go into the structure
right away so we recognize similar to
water and water we have hydrophobic and
hydrophilic to descry where the commode
can wear a surface or not now we
invented a new term we call this as
lethal phobic or lethal feeling to
describe the leaf inverting behavior so
the reason graphene oxide can where is
this pole of functional group of Oh H
COOH compared to the graphene or regular
carbon you don't have enough of these
polar group the polar group will react
with lithium these are proton will be
giving away so the reaction of the free
energy Delta G which between lithium and
graphene oxide is in two surface
reaction give you negative Delta G
driving the reaction happen and that
really means these elisa metal really
like this surface of bond phenoxide cost
of adding a phenomenon taking place this
reduced graphene oxide a percent by
weight only stacking into a layer
structure by filtration process and
putting into molten lithium react with
motor lithium we are we is a graphene
oxide and generally a little bit of
hydrogen bubble like these will you know
open the the spacing between a gap and
and the wetting happened the mortar
lithium will wear into the buffing oxide
and hiding now between the two graphene
oxide graphene oxide in this regard
is the whole structure for the lithium
metal and after this processing this is
flexible just like a metallic foil
this could be used using the existing
battery manufacturing machine you can
process that so now let's look at the
deposition behavior this is reduced
graphene oxide after deposition the
surface looks smooth if you deposit
least amount of copper foil formed this
damn joy so we don't have the standard
formation this made this lithium foil
inside the graphene oxide a lot more
stable a lot more say safer and as we
said and these type of Liam into the
graphene oxide lithium matter hiding
between you look at the cross-section of
this whole film and you strip lithium
away completely the only string is
thickness by about twenty percent so
it's now a lot more stable instead of
instead of becoming a completely empty
you have a whole structure that could
stabilize this metallic lithium you
place it back it come back to the
initial thickness these are making these
plating and stripping this is the
wattage profile this is a smaller one
tells you is stable the blue collar is
stable the red color is the regular
lithium foil the voltage open up is
telling you you need to use high and
high over potential it becomes less and
less stable so we have now a solution
that's a lot more stable the searching
of the house continued and the last year
or two also after graphene oxide we have
been able to identify a number of very
promising house materials now minimize
the volume change of the whole electro
now it's a virtually zero change down
that really apply wire stable materials
performed you can now play with
interface made easily tomato better so
that was the first topic I want to
select the one example to share with you
now let let me come to the second one so
Barry seems to be a black box it has
been a black box it is still too large
the degree of black box why he can
Stillwater be working
and we didn't have a full-page picture
of understanding down to Atami scale
how'd about his work so it's been about
more than ten years I have been always
thinking can we really using our TM just
missing electron microscopy to look at
the bare face however for most of the
benefit materials that I was not so
useful because Liam are moving all the
time and it's very materials you look at
the end or your soul reactive chemically
then we have is the moisture with oxygen
and also their melting point is usually
very low as soon as you focus electron
beam onto your bearing materials the
evaporate so it's really hard last year
you have seen this announcement in
October 2017 noble chemistry price was
giving to these three gentlemen they
invented the other ones the cryogenic
electron microscopy technique for
starting the biomolecule try to solve
the protein structure for example the
cryo year in the past ten years has a
lot of the Wiseman a used liquid
nitrogen or other really cold liquid to
cool down your biomolecule make it more
stable and also this is a very sensitive
detector can detect a signal with very
small dose of the electron one can
already image the protein in DNA RNA and
so on and this is what's the technique
my group have been used for about two
years now and - roughly two years ago I
recognized what biologists develop is
such a cool tool it might be very useful
for the battery research and these two
students were the hero and I talked to
them I said you guys stop your current
project let's work on a Manhattan
Project
why just complete new stuff I don't know
whether it's going to work by his words
were to spend a year or two of your
graduate life with me to explore this
area here
here is what they develop and we deposit
for example metallic lithium filament on
to TEM grid and put into liquid nitrogen
without exposed to air and really cool
down is very fast you stop your chemical
reaction liquid nitrogen that's at a
temperature of 77 Kelvin and they
develop a a chance for technique going
to transmission electron microscope we
Dow exposing to the air without leaving
the liquid nitrogen temperature so it'll
took them a while to do it so after
several months we have really surprised
data this is a lithium metal filament
using this choir am turning vehicle
image in the past as long as soon as you
image your metallic lithium fella may
look like dark color the reason is this
little matter already react with the
moisture in the air even with a second
exposure and that's the end of the world
why that will cause it become black
that's lithium metal she'll look like
this very like Kong just because it's an
element number three small atomic mass
it shouldn't have that much conscious
and the electron microscope and this is
already become lithium oxide lithium
carbonate this is the standard TM you
focus the electron beam you see you drew
a hole into this structure right away so
you cannot image them now he is aquarium
you can look at the structure for 1
minutes 5 minutes and 10 minutes they
still remain the same and using an
analytical tool called eels and electron
energy loss spectroscopy we can confirm
this is a metallic lithium we are
looking at instead of lithium is
metallic lithium
this is very exciting image when my
still the show to make me I say wow this
is just amazing
this is first time anybody can see a
Thomas scale image of metallic
lithium Lisa methyl is only a hundred
eighty degrees C melting pot the bonding
between lithium and lithium atom and
metallic lithium is very weak so now
it's possible to look at this atomic
scale a resolution and now we can even
look at a long beach or Direction
crystallography Clee metallic lithium
can grow these allowed to study the
gross habit eventually provide
information to solve the lithium the
entire problem we discover along 1 1 1
Direction is 50% of the damage I'd like
to do so around 230 percent 1 1 o 20%
these has a reason why a long certain
direction is more because the side wall
surface tend to terminate we is a
particular direction of a Quisling
surface one was zero that's the lowest
energy surface that actually can explain
this behavior it is also a long
outstanding issue in the battery
research field the ICO determines the
battery safety to a very large degree
that I can also determines the battery
life how many cycles you have how many
years you can your battery can run that
is actually the interface or electrolyte
interface there were two models proposed
in the past couple of decades about what
added structure at the surface the
interfacial layer of these materials
this is a multi-layer model is a mosaic
model mosaic model means and this
interfacial a you have inorganic
nanoparticles of the composition
compound embedded into the organic
matches of polymer so indeed under the
sea so SoCo ECT is electrolyte we can
identify this is schematic drawing of a
nanoparticle lithium oxide lithium
carbon a embedded into this green color
amorphous matrix or polymer decompose
and form through deselect by this
electrolyte we can identify if you could
see this image clearly a projection
in the screen atomic scale resolution
identify these inorganic particles into
organic matches however we have also
seen by adding an additive so-called FEC
into the electrolyte we can see the
multi-layer structure all for sei as
well in this case if is inorganic of
lithium oxide on top of the amorphous
matches of this polymer and these are
very two different structure of solid
electrolyte interface and this discovery
is indeed different from the initial
multi-layer model people proposed
initial people proposed is the inorganic
layer is underneath of these amorphous
polymer matches so we see the opposite
so you say why this is important why
this is important and a recent data and
published yet by my talented watch is
still in the sitting why there they see
it is two different morphology and they
give you a different interface impedance
resistance to the iron movement that
would change how the barrier material
such as lead a metal how they plate
what's their morphology and I can change
the efficiency of the plating and
stripping so for the columbic efficiency
that can determine your battery cycling
life can be long or short so the ability
to understand this and to correlate this
structure with electrochemical
performance eventually hopefully we can
design artificially a very nice
interface probably allow us to make the
battery run much longer cycle life in
calendar life
so I was attached the third topic about
the battery safety
it's still hopeful you can make the bear
is safe
we know battery Enza has organic
actually you have seen the instance over
the years where is airplane to the where
it's more you know phone device it's a
couple of years ago or no seven oh this
happened periodically everyone's where
every two years also you always see a
big instance coming in and this instance
usually come from a reason you have a
battery cell it could be external it
could be internal you have some type of
shorting happening so this many reasons
can cause this shorting and externally
you have accident outside force
you know bomb into your bare face can
cause the shorting internally you might
have defect you may have charged have
charged your bare face overcharged and
you might charge in a cold weather low
temperature and internally can grow
elite in danger
no matter what's the reason these will
cause fast release of the battery
electricity the bear has started to heat
up at about 100 degrees roughly this
range the interfacial layer of your end
will start to have exothermic
decomposition that's why I was telling
you as SGI is quite important this
interfacial layer can I find your
battery safety in your cycle life and
the temperature keeps going up because
you are releasing more and more
electricity about 180 degrees cells is
also exothermic reaction between the
careful oxide and your real actual I
start to happen and this will quickly
hit how your battery to 300 degrees C
400 degrees is 600 degrees C this is
called thermal runaway so at this moment
it's very hard to stop nearly impossible
to stop the reaction so this thermal
runaway can across the barrier catching
files and the worst case
we'll be expulsion happen looking at
this issue we have been trying to come a
new solution to prevent an each stage of
the problem let me share with you with
three ideas one idea is if you have
internal plating of metallic lithium can
you inside this battery separator this
positive electric kettle and know this
is separate at the yellow color in the
middle is a red dash line is a metallic
about 100 nanometers or 200 enemy is a
very thin coating put in the middle and
instead of having to electro let's have
three electro for each battery cell if
you have a shorting happening grow
halfway you detect this middle layer
with your end now you see the voltage
goes to nearly zero that tells you the
shorting is coming it's halfway
you better stop your battery charging
and don't use your battery anymore so
make it safe till that's our solution
number one these can help addressing the
problem of plating if you're barely has
manufacturing defect and that can cause
the plating halfway let's stop using it
the second one is what if you cannot
prevent that your battery has to heat up
then you need to have a fire
extinguishing mechanism going in and we
can put fire retardant encapsulated into
this polymer for example and you you can
put in this green color fire retardant
and capsule into the polymer the polymer
smelting pawn can be engineered to the
temperature you want for example 100
degrees Celsius around that if you get
to that temperature the polymer melt and
then release this fire retardant so you
can now prevent a battery Catching Fire
we have also work with a professor to
number in chemical engineering to say
well let's find out switching mechanism
to make a battery saver if you have a
shorting happening in one of these
current collector we have a polymer
layer these are
nano spike of nickel embed inside and
loon temperature is conducting but your
battery heat up to high temperature this
polymer volume expand and put a nickel
nano spy a lot of this particle open so
the whole layer become an insulator made
a release of the electricity very hard
so you don't heat up your battery that
much you have a thermo switching you can
control that to about close to 100 100
degree Celsius also and these are
electric conductivity going from
metallic to insulator have a control
temperature so in a small cell d3
mechanism work reasonably well now we
try to explore this for the large cell
use in your phone and your in your car
well these are three ideas adding
together
mimei you're very much saver
I'd like to come to the fourth topic
riskier storage this is complete defense
grid scale store is compared to the year
transportation batteries
it does not require high energy density
in principle it does not require while
you cannot also go to our chose more
energy density won't work from the cost
consideration also from the
consideration of the real estate the
landing occupy he will not work either
you still need certain energy density I
want to share with you a couple ideas on
this topic we know gryska energy store
is so important for us to integrate
solar and also win into the electric
grid it help us to stabilize the grid
for us to have a much smarter grid a
Stanford right here we have bits and
what initiated is exact try to dealing
with to reconsider how we do do the grid
for the grid scale storage this
opportunity for the bearers could to
contribute to smooth out of fluctuation
from seconds to minutes to hour and also
to do the pig shifting in our store
electricity
when there's a lot of generation not
that much use and then use it later when
you have a peak use and from ours today
and also seasonal storage we have a lot
of solar during the summer time but now
in the winter time and certainly
seasonal storage is a lot harder the
easier one to start with could be these
seconds to minutes to hours the more
cycle of the battery you use the better
for the bear fits in terms of the cost
consideration seasonal storage you use
it about one to two cycles per year so
that's not a good use of your batteries
from the cost for the probably the
largest application is in the peak
shifting let's look at the current
storage still the pumping the water it's
the most low-cost one for storage and
due to the elevation difference pumping
it during the electricity storage and
use it and then throw the water down
this has the location dependence or the
you know getting the plumie will be very
hard these has limited use right there
let's look at the grease can store is
what how big of scared that could be
several years ago when I give the top
right here and the energy seminar our
annual production of lithium ion battery
is only about half of this size 2017 the
data will come out soon by what predict
is about bubble about four years ago
seventy gigawatt hour but in California
alone from Greece care storage we
probably need fifty gigawatt hour easily
we need that and you put a whole year
production you know it's just barely can
satisfy a California need for the
lithium ion and and how many batteries
we need right there we need this
Stanford Stadium the football stadium
feel to have all this pathways that will
be sufficient for us to use is a big
problem
so this idea you know can we consider
different idea for the storage if you
look at now what are the options
actually siomay and still a very strong
contender it's the cost going down so
fast no other batteries have lithium
ions performance and cost yet
let us it's a very low cost however land
has only have three to four years
lifetime and lithium-ion is longer and
flow pathway has been considered is this
liquid consists of a redox molecules you
can charge up these a Rito's molecule by
flowing one way and discharge in flow
way back when adium a result is well
known at this moment is there high-cost
membrane cause right here is very
important that's a is likely membrane
doesn't allow the redox of these a is to
go through but only the protons it's a
high cost and also the energy density is
low for this redox molecules all
abilities no enough you're talking about
3100 per kilo that's about seven times
lower than lithium ion with all the
controlling electronics going in the
system level cost lithium ion now is
about 250 ml per kilo
I'm sorry per kilowatt-hour 250 and a
redox flow is about 400 500 range it's
still too high so if you could increase
the energy you stole you can reduce the
cost number of years ago we showed
lithium poly sulfa has much higher
solubility and compared to one adium
that's 1.7 molar and a lithium poly
sulfide can have even 5x more so you
increase the money or energy you stole
you reduce the cost and we invented is a
technology with the metallic lithium
anode so you have a solid you have a
liquid they react by themself forming
this self decomposition compound SDI
that's your membrane
you don't have to use other membrane in
reduce the cause this still remain as a
very attractive idea of a semi flow
battery is - for the grease gas storage
we show these can cycle for you know
thousand cycle type of range still going
I also want to highlight in the last
year or two
also my gloob was just started a new
project and looks very promising what
general is a pasta in the group or
working on this project and we look at
what might be the possible choice it
turned out to be these could be a
attractive solution for grease care is a
nickel hydrogen gas barefaced let me
clarify is no nickel metal hydride it's
a nickel the same as nickel metal
hydride but the hydrogen is different
nickel metal hydride using hydrogen
store and the arrow here we only use gas
and basically if one is soleal actual
that's an eco oxyhydroxide and nickel
hydroxide cycling back and forth during
charging but the end no is hydrogen in
water and building up this battery is
simple so it's a taking the nickel
hydroxide in water and putting the
catalyst for the hydrogen and into this
electro you build it out in the
discharges state once you charge it up
you general hydrogen gas and put it into
a tank so it's also an idea or semi flow
graph it have a solid the others have is
guess you only have flow the other have
very simple construction and this has
the very long cycle life this show you
are more than 1200 cycles without decay
is about one month reward aqueous
solution batteries very low cost and
these have showed these a choir amazing
performance for a quest system this can
potentially get up to 130 water per
kilogram in a lattice it's only 30 40
the usual redox flow is about 30 40 this
about three times higher and the wall of
magic is it's not bad the key thing is
we think the cycle life can go to 10,000
cycles we have done the limited a couple
thousand cycles virtually without decay
and this extremely important Canada life
could be 25 years how do I know that
after we invented this way and I
searched in the literature we say let's
see whether people have worked on this
before it turned out to be tense a few
decades ago and NASA NASA used this
chemistry for the satellite so you go to
the satellite if you don't have 25 years
you are not allowed to get into
satellite and but why why did we forget
about this battery chemistry that's
because at that time the n-nope are
using platinum as catalyst that's high
cost now we have different catalysts for
our hydrogen electrode mater how bad is
much lower cost
these can potentially get down to these
a $50 per kilowatt hour type or range so
this also very attractive solution for
grease care storage eventually we are
looking for $100 per kilowatt hour so
this is a good starting point in the
last few minutes let me mention now the
issue of the resource availability for
the bare face let's mention the Liam
first I show some of this slide before
we have a 40 million term of global
reserve for lithium this is going up
this number is this it mouth are we
worried about the availability of
lithium so let's do a little bit of
analysis this 40 million ton is enough
for us to make a 10 billion is on leave
and if you try Tesla that will give you
a three billion Tesla that's an still
knowing now why we have about billion
car running in the world right now and
but don't forget we have virtually
infinite amount of lithium in the ocean
indeed looking at this number Steve Chu
and I recently
in a project to extract leave them out
of ocean and now it looks a quiet
promising and we could do that we can
beat sodium chloride and the ocean
integrity mile and the cause it's not
quite meeting the cost or from this
research reserve yet but as long as the
lithium concentration increase slightly
and it doesn't need to be those very
salty like having a lot of highly team
concentration just a little bit higher
than the ocean we will be economically
viable so I think this issue potentially
can be solved availability of lithium
but I do want to pour now you know what
what are the possibility for the Greece
scale with the current lithium Reserve
our electricity consumption about 510 or
maybe a little bit higher now to stop
four hours of the electricity of the
whole world
we need about sixteen terawatt hour over
bare face and our forty million time for
it's enough for us to make 240 tell one
hour in that regard we still have a lot
of lithium I still need to want you
lithium is not just useful purpose it's
useful aircrafts as where I consume a
lot more lithium than a battery to main
light wave lightweight arrow so let me
show you how sensitive the lithium price
could be in the last several years
starting from 2015 China announced
electric are significant support for the
electric car program and the Elysium
price go up tremendously up to that and
it is a large number of electric cars so
little past couple years you can see 5x
price increase just not running the
shortage of lithium yet but these are
you know the man in supply is you can
drive the price in a very sensitive way
let's also looking at the issue of other
important element inside the batteries
and no using graphite cathode in the
current technology using lithium cobalt
oxide lithium cobalt nickel manganese
oxide let's look at the cobalt price
and it's 2017 that's right that you see
the price rise 3.5 x reaching a $35 per
kilogram this price is too high that's
why you see you see recently all the
Barrett company say let's go to hi Nico
MMC let's don't use that much cobalt
because the co boy is too expensive
we have limited availability of COBOL
they become an issue nickel price is
about $6 per kilo not that expensive yet
but once we go to the large diploma of
electric car and moving into the grid
using these materials and the nickels of
availability the price could become an
issue as well also watch for the copper
we use a lot of copper foil for an now
if we use a lot more copper we also need
to watch that as well
so we list that which we say what is a
strong motivation let's don't use those
metal they can be expensive they have
limited availability developing a
lithium sulfur chemistry becomes
attractive software is everywhere these
I believe this is the mountain of
software in Canada so you don't know
what to use this for it's just pie right
there the the cause is less than $1 per
kilogram so it's so much cheaper and
this can offer you Liam cassava
chemistry can offer you practically
perhaps in the future three times of the
energy density compared to current
technology so I also want to touch upon
lesion battery recycling these delete
him/her cause means the COBOL cost you
look at this basic structure what are
the valuable stuff inside the batteries
from end of the copper foil cooperates
variable we want to take the copper out
graph i particle to have you'd only
graphite graphite we have a lot a lot
more you know they are not worse to be a
recycle your separator is just polymer
polyethylene polypropylene so you can
burn it that's probably fine
and Liam copper oxide right has Cobalt
this I can have a little nickel oxide I
have nickel this needs to be recycled
the high cost of and in an aluminum foil
aluminum is cheap that's okay if you
don't recycle that so these are the
wearable stuff in order to cycle your
lithium back you don't want your lithium
and the charge is stay going to end or
you actually want it to return all the
way back to the cathode they store in
the lithium cobalt oxide then you lose
cycle cobalt and leave them together
right so you look at existing battery
recycling technology this is the one
first of all when you collect these
batteries in mind not in the discharges
that it could still have a lot of
electricity is right there it could be
dangerous it's a it's a bomb so let's
discharge that first but you don't want
to have a robot or individual to go
connect it and show the batteries so
that costs too much and the idea is
actually people are smart they throw
into the salty water the salt salty
water can tie electricity
you saw all the battery inside right and
then you can discharge that after 25
hours this this part is easy to do but
the next part is so much harder so how
do you recycle that once you look at
that I say well don't forget about it
don't don't look at it right so it's
just too many steps the cost is too high
the rough idea is you take the batteries
and then you break them into small
pieces and then you and then you leach
out
lithium cobalt nickel and then you
separate them and take their mouth
use strong acid and you consume a lot of
energy to recycle them and the cause is
true high there's no a good way to
recycle the batteries yet I charge my a
challenging my student and also order
steel and sitting right there you guys
need to think about how to recycle
batteries this problem is coming very
fast right no test last car
the first batch in a few years will
retire this huge enamel barrier will be
recycled
we need to figure out this problem soon
- so a couple more question I want to
answer very quickly will end my talk so
what about also least a bare-faced if
you do that you make them safer in
principle yes saurus they can use
ceramics in the past several years a lot
of progress made people know how to make
solid state the iron conduction is so
least a very fast as highest liquid even
higher than liquid so that's great the
challenging is interface how to combine
solid state the solid state which always
volume expansion without cracking and
also the solid electrolyte is very
brittle if you use ceramics if you use
polymers suddenly that's better
but polymers ionic conductivity needs to
to be improved so still quite early we
will not be able to see so least a
batteries and deploy in a significant
scale and it and in any time very soon
what about fast charging how fast can
you do that so what's the fast charging
problem you have and know you have
careful if you do fast charging you push
lithium-ion electricity too fast
these are graphite and now will not be
able to take it the lithium so fast and
there's also temple although potentially
is too high you go through the dope you
love the 0 1 vs lithium you're going to
pay how lithium tender you will go down
to show your batteries that's very
challenging so people have known figure
out yet these fast charging unless you
use other end all such as lithium
titanium oxide the voltage is very high
and for the end no the potential you can
do fast charging less than 10 minutes
but you also lose half of your energy
density because your inner potential is
too high your food cell and your food
cell voltage is about half so how do you
maintain reasonably high energy and do
fast charging we don't know how to do
and the polymer energy you recently have
has a proposal called asking for ideal
how to solve this problem so we'll see
whether great ideas can come what about
swapping the batteries is this
still viable approach
if we have too many electric cars on the
road
we don't have fast charging our real
estate price in Palo Alto in San
Francisco will be too high we probably
want to figure how fast charging all
some type of swapping batteries and the
swapping battery I think this is ideas
they're not that when I talk to the
companies in the Beijing is a Beijing
real estate prices so high there's no
way they can having so many cars
swapping ideas this idea might be coming
back so what about other things sodium
magnesium aluminum bath is you heard a
lot about this right in the in the
papers in the news this this is very
exciting from the mental research right
there you have to remember sodium ion is
bigger than lithium so though that's a
little harder to move sodium magnesium
is to plus aluminum that to plus they
are harder but they do all for the
potential sodium magnesium aluminum
they're a lot cheaper what if the Liam
become a problem then you should have
this as a backup I think we should do
that we should have fundamental research
working on this but the challenging
right here measure you have to have the
right kettle right and know right
actually and saw the whole system for
all these new chemistry they're not
there and this could take many years
before we get there so for the next 10
years or longer time for transportation
it will be mainly the world of lithium
base bare-faced will be half of sodium
magnesium aluminum to come into mega
impact it will be still lithium and
there's a lot of room to improve the
issues I already mentioned and the
opportunities there energy density cause
life safety resource availability
recycling increase gear storage the
opportunity are wide open there's not a
winner yet for the Greece care storage
it might be lithium
we saw such a you know portable
electronics driving force electric car
driving force perhaps the lesion will go
down to the cost very fast and gets the
grease scale flow battery has a shot and
our new nickel hydrogen gas benefit this
might be the one the new chemistry
showing great potential this other
aqueous solution bear here also show you
know based on sodium ion for example
might have the great potential well let
me end my talk by thanking the whole
research group the support for many of
my collaborators over the years and also
locally many of you have been the either
cheerleaders and for example Jesus I
have providing a lot of funding over the
years and thank you very much for your
attention I will be happy to take any
questions you have
and firstly we're gonna happen give up
our AV equipment we can take questions
after let's take one or two very quick
questions any student questions about
one of the major challenges maybe two
the first one is the we still use the
solvent that's flammable either based
solvent the can burn easily and catch
fire the second one the place relates to
performance the Columbia efficiency is
not high enough yet we still lose
lithium its cycle in order to get to a
long cycle life calendar life with
limited Manoli tomatoes to studies we
still need to solve that problem
I know should qualify 2.5 to 3 times and
yet the charging rate that is hoped to
go down five and although manages but
nowhere did you reference any operating
temperature inside the medium of the
battery which I imagine without proof
can be fairly high so now that's that's
a question you know I think that the
temperature issue has to be addressed
which apparently is not yet secondarily
the addendum question has to do with the
usefulness of using cryo e/m to look at
every structure I can imagine that
chromium is so low okay you do
post-accident analysis but yet what
image structure doesn't replicate the
structure at the time of failure because
of thermal
such as thermal oceans and etc etc so
what was what's the use of Caillou um
immediately given those circumstances
yeah
the first question is the insider
temperature of the batteries we need to
fast charging that is an issue
absolutely on the issue you do fast
charging we all know if you do fast the
battery is a cycle life will be shorter
because it's a lot of bad things happen
we don't know how to solve that yet so
that needs to be done and but I also
take that as an opportunity maybe a
great idea is if you want to do fast
charging try to tune your electrolyte
fast charging at elevated temperature
the kinetics go very fast
I like to do fast charging that might be
an opportunity so the second question is
the query n looking at the freeze of
frozen structure how do you use that to
represent a dynamic process inside the
battery doesn't the essence of your
question what we could do is at a
different stage of operation you freeze
that fast you freeze that snapshot and
then put it into the TM the cryo am to
look at it carefully now and you freeze
in this different stage allow you to
build up a kind of a semi video to
reflect what's happening that will be
massive
[Applause]
you